[Musica]
qualche anno fa mi sono reinventata
mixando delle discipline un po come nel
video che vi avevamo prima dai molti poi
penso di esserne una creando un lavoro
che effettivamente unico tutto mio
io sono una marketer e mi occupo di
autostima femminile usando i tacchi come
strumento di empowerment questa cosa
piace tantissimo la stampa quindi mi
intervistano molto spesso anche riviste
nazionali giornali eccetera
ogni volta che esco sulla stampa mando
una cernita di foto abbastanza vasta
perché loro possano illustrare gli
articoli molti giornali usano le mie
foto la grande scelta era quella che vi
ho fatto vedere prima questa qui è però
a volte fanno attingono ai loro archivi
facendo delle scelte a volte discutibili
oggi vi racconterò cosa è successo
qualche anno fa con una di queste scelte
discutibili che cosa fa un giornale
quando deve illustrare un articolo non
hanno voluto scegliere le mie vai a
sapere perché prendono i loro archivi e
soprattutto avviene un lavoro di re
interpretazione dell'articolo come
sentivamo qualche spiccio prima il mondo
è come lo vediamo noi e quindi loro
inviano ai loro lettori
la loro visione di quello che io gli ho
raccontato questo articolo uscito
qualche anno fa per un evento locale di
empowerment femminile
una domenica pomeriggio io non ero molto
contento a 0 proprio una iena quindi
telefono la giornalista che aveva fatto
un'intervista meravigliosa bellissima
parlavamo di cose fantastiche ii
consenti come mai hai messo quella foto
latino mandate tantissime non sono
arrivate che è successo fa nono la
scelgo io sai scelgono i titoli c'è il
titolista le foto le scegli un altro
ma tu non puoi capire io sono una iena
per questa cosa questo qua un esempio
lampante di oggettificazione del corpo
femminile che demolisce tutto il lavoro
che io faccio con le donne
per me è gravissimo e lei candida mi
dice ma dai è solo una foto ma dai
dovevano vendere ma dai devono attirare
l'attenzione ma dai si fa così quante
volte la sentiamo questa cosa anche
dicendola noi stessi ma dai è solo una
pubblicità ma dai la moda lo sai quel
mondo ma dai ma dai come la dai
c'è una nuance molto forte
io ho riflettuto molto a questo è il
fatto che lei non avesse capito la
gravità nell'ecosistema sociale
dell'oggettistica zione del corpo
femminile
questa fotografia io non so voi ma io
non mi vesto così di pomeriggio per me
non è poi così normale andare in giro
così
no non so io non mi metto vediamo
proviamo su un divano così quando ricevo
i miei clienti e gli parlo del progetto
che devo fare
non lo so vi sembra normale una cosa del
genere metterla su un giornale per un
evento pomeridiano vi sembra normale che
la pubblicità veicoli la donna in modo
completamente oggettificazione fai dire
oggettificazione che cos'è lo getti
ficazione del corpo e prenderne solo una
parte nel caso della donna anche
sessuali zando la e usandola soltanto
come un oggetto per uno scopo preciso
queste sono tutte pubblicità
attualissime della nuova e non il
problema è che non capiamo le
conseguenze nell'ecosistema sociale
quando tu prendi un corpo qual è la
differenza fra una persona un oggetto io
non è che vanno dalla mia lavatrice e le
dico cara ti fa
risparmi una centrifuga ci stai me la
fai
no io dico alla macchina faina
centrifuga la uso non la uso si rompe e
la brutto quando oggettivi chiamo un
corpo soprattutto quello della donna
diamo sempre lo stesso messaggio è un
oggetto non ha la parola la fotografia
che rappresentava il mio articolo non
c'era la testa c'erano soltanto le gambe
i tacchi le calze a rete
il problema è che tutte queste campagne
vanno poi fuori contesto
perché vengono sparate nel mondo
quindi le vedono tutti tutta la
popolazione
anche i bambini e c'è un bombardamento
tale di immagini di questo genere ogni
giorno da quando nascono e hanno
capacità di intendere i bambini sono
spugne l'essere umano impara anche per
emulazione per adattamento ci abbattiamo
tutti continuamente l'abbiamo sentito
anche in altri speech tutte queste cose
non sono prive di conseguenze stanno
educando le persone fin da piccole ad
avere alle donne
un'immagine del loro corpo completamente
irreale perché il modello e lo sappiamo
bene ma dai a una pubblicità ma dai è
una modella
il modello completamente il real è
addirittura photoshoppato neanche quella
modella ii e reale nella pubblicità e
agli uomini ai bambini e poi adolescenti
uomini a vedere la donna come un oggetto
da usare e di cui disporre da cui
nascono tantissimi stereotipi sulle
donne serio tipiche veicoliamo anche noi
stesse perché siamo immerse negli stessi
stimoli
quante adolescenti io ne conosco tante
poi le becco ai miei corsi le trentenni
quarantenni insicure noi gli short non
me li metto perché sono grassa vai a
dire un adolescente di 16 anni che non
vuole andare al mare perché non ha
superato la prova costume non si vuole
mettere in questione
questo è un problema di sanita
sociale più che familiare perché molte
famiglie non arrivano a educare i loro
figli a capire la differenza e se ci
pensiamo bisogna andare a spiegare che
questa cosa non è reale quindi bisogna
lasciarla stare per poi spiegare 1 ma
aspetta guarda che ma dai è una
pubblicità lo certifica zione del corpo
femminile sta annullando la diversità la
normalità ma nulla tranquilli quasi
allora che cos'è la normalità che cos'è
il modello non di certo la modella
stanga qualcuno esiste
i corpi normali hanno un po di pancia
hanno la cellulite
abbiamo forme del corpo diverse è
difficile far capire a una bambina una
ragazza che quella roba lì non è reale
perché gliela diamo in pasto tutti i
giorni fin da quando è nata ok quindi di
recente mi è successa una cosa molto
strana questa sono io al lavoro ma avete
visto anche prima ho scelto tanto sulle
riviste una mia fan mi ha scritto molto
premurosa dicendo veronica sai ora che
esci tanto sulle riviste le ragazze ti
seguono
dovresti dimagrire qualche chilo per
dare il buon esempio
io sono poliglotta sono laureata o
un'azienda solo professore universitario
motivo le donne a lascia a smettere di
pensare al loro aspetto e pensare di più
alle loro azioni nonché un corpo in
salute non vada bene anzi va benissimo
ma non dipendiamo più dal nostro aspetto
per la nostra sopravvivenza come le ore
prima con un buon matrimonio se non ti
sposabile [ __ ] è finita siamo
indipendenti
yeah siamo però rimaste sintonizzate sul
corpo che è veicolo di sopravvivenza
io questa ragazza non sapevo cosa dire
ho cercato esperto cavola grosso
lavorando malissimo
che errore ho fatto ecco perché loggiati
ficazione del corpo femminile è talmente
radicata nel nostro ecosistema che un
problema sociale che non possiamo più
ignorare
io ho due proposte o due proposte la
prima è molto seria o mi si è aperto
tutto
la prima è molto seria e riguarda la
legge non fare causa e quelli che fanno
le pubblicità strane ma legiferare
voi sapete che una pubblicità prima di
andare in onda o sui cartelloni subisce
un iter di controllo nazismo o torniamo
indietro
rimaniamo li nazismo
se sono alimenti se c'è troppo zucchero
troppo sale ormai devono mettere una
scritta via via aggiungiamo paletti a
questo iter di controllo nelle
pubblicità oggettificazione del corpo
femminile
non pervenuta io non mi fermerò e tante
come me non ci fermeremo finché questo
paletto non farà parte dell'iter di
approvazione di una pubblicità con una
legge a livello europeo
e questa la prima proposta e questo fa
parte del mio lavoro di attivista in
modo attivo ma io sono una
ed è qua siamo tanti la gente che ci
guarda poi su youtube e ancora
tantissimi dicono che le rivoluzioni non
si fanno sulla tastiera
balle le rivoluzioni si fanno a tavolino
e sono economiche e non si fanno più in
strada
io sono stata all 8 marzo e strada
eravamo pochissime le rivoluzioni si
fanno anche sulla testiera e sono
economiche e possiamo farne parte perché
perché viviamo in un momento storico
dove noi abbiamo per la prima volta la
capacità e la la possibilità di
interagire con i brand che fanno queste
pubblicità con il marketing
noi possiamo rispondere e anzi loro nel
marketing cercano il dialogo la combo
seychelles cercano l'engagement quindi
vogliono che lo gli rispondiamo io
quello che propongo è molto semplice
dato che noi gli diamo noi i miliardi
che incassano siamo piccoli uno non
conta tutti insieme conta le rivoluzioni
delle tastiere si fanno educando il
marketing perché il marketing che educa
i nostri bambini dobbiamo rieducarlo e
come possiamo fare semplicissimo come si
educa un bambino non li cena si fa a
bruto è perché non capisce cosa un po
come fai a spiegargli che un
comportamento una certa azione non va
bene gli si guarda ai fatto kakà fuori
dal vasino andrebbe fatta nel vasino
perché molto meglio per questo e
quest'altro motivo lo vede quelli lo
spieghi non sono stupidi bambini
capiscono mari e ripeti una 235 mille
volte spegne le luci
quante volte ce l'hanno ripetuto fino
allo le scelti tantissimi quindi devi
martellare bisogna essere costanti e
anche se c'è un comportamento virtuosity
bravo l'hai fatta nel vasino
ecco quindi c'è una spiegazione del
perché rispettosa non va lo hai fatto la
pubblicità testo stati norio non serve a
molto
insegniamo gli facciamogli capire che il
mercato non siamo d'accordo quindi il
punto è il mercato siamo noi
madri figlie padri riduciamo la
pubblicità
diventiamo attivisti da tastiera perché
noi siamo milioni e soprattutto noi
siamo milioni di culi
grazie
[Applauso]